그래서 이거는 좀 되게 의미가 깊은
사례인 거 같아요이 두 사례를
보면서도 압구정 로에 계속 최고가를
경신하는 이런 사례들이 좀 많이
나오지 않을까 뭐 이렇게 조심스럽게
예상을 해
봅니다네 안녕하세 빌사남 있니다 제가
오늘은 압구정 로가 심상치 않다라는
주제로 좀 촬영을 하려고 하는데 어
압구정 로가 어떤 도로면 여기
한남대교 가기 전에 이쪽 부분에서부터
저기 청담 사거리까지이 대로변입니다
그래서 여기가 왜 심상치 냐면 어
최근에 아마 언론 기사로 좀 많이
보셨을 거예요 앞구정 아파트 지구라고
해서 여기 이제 높이 제한이나 이런
그 용도가 좀 완화된다 규제가
완화된다는 그 기사들이 좀 많이
나갔거든요 여기가 이제 압구정 현대랑
여기 재건축 단지들이 있는 곳이고
여기를 맞다 부분이 바로 앞구정
로입니다 그래서 최근에 여기에 빌딩이
한 두 건 정도 매각이 되는데 그
사례를 좀 소개하려고 합니다 그래서
최근에 여기 압구 정로의 좀 찾아
달라는 분이 좀 많이 생겨 놨거든요
이게 나중에 재건축 되고 나서 좀
이쪽 건너편에 좀 더 좋아지지
않을까라는 기대 심리로 좀 투자를
생각하시는 분들이 생겨난 거
같습니다요 최근에 매각 된이 두 건
정도의 사례를 같이 좀 소개를 해
드리겠습니다 어 우선 첫 번째 사례는
여기
가로수길 있는 쪽이에요네 가로수길 그
위쪽에 거기 악구 정로의 맞다 있는
부분인데이 건물 같은 경우에는
2021년도 3월 달에 300억 원에
매입을 한 다음에 그니까 이제
2023년 8월 달에 40억의 매각이
됐습니다 그래서 때 뭐 건축 행위를
따로 한 건 아니에요이 건물이 그래서
매입 지한 거의 2년
만에네요 건물입니다
2021년도에 300억 원에 매입해서
그냥이 상태 그대로 410억 원에
2023년 8월 달에 매각을 했습니다
땅 가격으로 치면은 한 2억 8천이
정도 되는 거 같아요 근데 여기 고정
로가 상업지가 아닙니다 상업지가
아니고 3종이에요
그런데도 땅 가격이 상당히
높습니다 그리고 아마 전 영상에 제가
유튜브로을 했었는데이 사례가 좀 저는
되게 좀 놀라웠어요 앞구정 로에
요쪽에 갤러리아 백화점
반대편에네 이렇게 전면이 긴 빌딩
아마 잘 아실 겁니다 이쪽 근처에
사시는 분들은 그래서요 건물이
800억에 매각이 됐습니다 그래서 땅
가격으로 치면은 거의 한 4억 5천
정도 돼요네 4억 5천 정도 됩니다
앞구정 로에서 그래도 위치가 좀 되게
좋은 쪽에 속하는 그런 건물인데 이게
일단은 4억 5천이면 거의
도산대로 수준의 가격이거든요 도산
대로는 지금 상업지도 같이 껴 있는데
이거 같은 경우에는
3종입니다 지금 3층짜리 건물인데
여기서 만약에 건물이 뭐 더 올라가도
뭐 한 4층 많나봐요
5층입니다이
3종에 정로의 물론 대로변에 전면이
넓은
이건물을 억원에 매입을
했습니다 그래서 이거는 좀 되게
의미가 깊은 사례인 거 같아요 요거를
나중에 이제 어떻게 개발할지 잘
모르겠는데이 두 사례를 보면서도
압구정 로에 계속 최고가를 경신하는
이런 사례들이 좀 많이 나오지 않을까
뭐 이렇게 조심스럽게 예상을 해
봅니다 그리고 지금 압구 정로의 같이
이렇게 맞대고 있는 여기 청담동 명품
거리도 2 3년 전만해도 좀 상황이
좋지 않았어요 공 도 굉장히 많고
근데 최근에는 분위기가 많이 바뀌면서
여기 일대가 거의 다 만실이고 지금
상황들이 되게 좋아졌습니다 그래서
앞으로 앞구정 로가 좀 많이 변하지
않을까네 뭐 이렇게 예상을 하는데
저는 개인적인 생각으로 여기 이제
재건축이 되고 초고층 그런 아파트들이
많이 생겨나고 뭐 이런 초과
아파트들이 많이 생겨나면 요일 가
전체적으로 좀 가격이 오르지 않을까네
그렇게 저 개인적으로는 예상을 합니다
그래서 오늘 영상은 제가 압구정 로에
대해서 좀 설명을 드렸는데 여러분들도
압구정 로가 앞으로 좀 어떻게 변할지
그리고이 사례들을 왜 샀는지 조금
시간을 두고 지켜보시면 어 좀 좋을
것 같습니다 뭔가 좀 재밌을 것
같아요 저 800억 리 건물도 나중에
진짜 4년 뒤 5년 뒤 뭐 10년
뒤에 어떻게 바뀔지 좀 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 제가
말씀드렸던 재건축이 되면서 정말
최고가 아파트들이 생겨나면서 주변이
좀 어떻게 변할지도 한번 좀
지켜보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그래서
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다